so what are oxalates in phytic acid then
so phytic acid is a large molecule uh
that chelates meaning it bites onto a
mineral plants use phytic acid to store
minerals they need to store the minerals
like phosphorus and calcium and
manganese and magnesium because they use
those to germinate once the seed
actually germinates like a brazil nut is
a seed it doesn't have selenium in it
for you it has selenium in it for the
actual plant when it wants to grow into
a brazil plant right so the way that it
holds onto that mineral is with a
compound called phytic acid which
chelates those minerals
oxalate is another compound it's a
dicarboxylic acid so it's a much smaller
two carbon molecule and it but it also
can prevent the absorption of these
molecules by binding to them and pulling
them out of your gut so when we're
talking about nutrients
all of these discussions should be
framed in terms of bioavailability
how much of that nutrient can you
actually get out of that plant because
let's just think about spinach like when
you're eating spinach do you think are
you eating it because you're like i'm
getting a certain mineral out of it or a
vitamin or something
i'm eating it because
i do think that there are some some some
nutrients to it but i also think that
there's fiber in it as well and so just
for
regularity and keeping fiber up i think
well i might as well add a whole bunch
of spinach it disappears it's
calorically
pretty minimal
um you can put big handfuls in the pan
and cook it down and it's like nothing
so spinach is actually a really
interesting one because spinach is very
hot don't don't no no no don't worry my
life you're going to ruin my life
oxalates knowledge is power you're
welcome i know i'm walking that's
exactly why i'm talking to you
no it's actually really high in oxalate
and if you go to any so a mainstream
kidney doctor which we call a
nephrologist if you have kidney stones
uh most skinny stones in the world i
think 80 are calcium oxalate kidney
stones where do we get oxalate we get
oxalate from things like almonds spinach
rhubarb beets beet greens very high in
oxalates and these oxalates can
accumulate in humans and we don't really
fully understand this we haven't really
studied it because who is funding this
so we know pretty clearly even i'm going
to ruin your life i'm just ruining your
life danny i'm sorry you know hey look
my people all know like they're all like
what are you eating these days i mean
this can be like
you know sweet haley who's been with me
for 14 years she's like so what what are
you eating these days because i will
evolve my diet based on more information
so
okay let me have it
so chocolate also it's pretty high in
oxalates as is turmeric turmeric uh jen
we need to end this interview it's over
i'm talking about i told you
like
so we know there's been studies where
they give people now this is a lot of
chocolate it's like two to four ounces
of chocolate this is like valentine's
day amounts of chocolates but you can
see that in their urine the oxalic acid
goes up to levels that are pathological
you get the amount of oxalate in your
urine is the same as somebody with like
a genetic condition that causes
oxalate dumping and massive urinary
stones in the kidneys staghorn calculi
so if you eat that's with two to four
ounces of chocolate i'm just saying like
chocolate has a lot of oxalates and you
can push the amount of oxalic acid in
your kidneys very high and you can
excrete it but maybe it forms a stone or
maybe it deposits somewhere in your body
so there's been autopsy studies also of
human thyroids there's no role for
oxalic acid and human thyroids when they
look at autopsies the majority of human
thyroids have oxalate deposits in them
and so the question is like okay what is
oxalic acid doing in the thyroid is it
potentially harmful and then we see
lower levels of oxalate in people whose
thyroids are affected by autoimmune
thyroid conditions like hashimoto's
thyroiditis so you think okay this is
just all hypothesis but this is the type
of thing that i want my work to make
western medicine ask these questions is
it possible that some autoimmunity at
the level of the thyroid is triggered by
a reaction against oxalate being
deposited in the thyroid there's no real
critical role for oxalate in the human
body it's a waste product when you break
down certain amino acids you excrete a
small amount of oxalic acid oxalate but
when you dump spinach into your bison
you're just pushing that oxalate up and
up and up and you're just making more
and more oxalates to be deposited
everywhere joints thyroid kidneys i mean
this is probably the worst one there's a
whole group of people out there who have
vulvar pain
that resolves when they stop eating
oxalates it's called vulvodynia they
can't sit like women can't sit
because it hurts so badly
to sit in the vulva like
from
and it appears to be related to oxalate
deposition in the in the in the nether
regions in the most precious part you
know in the most tender regions
so this is just one of these type of
things that says like okay
is spinach really good for you let's ask
the question and try and understand how
you know danica and all your listeners
thrive the best moving forward there's
no nutrients in spinach that you can't
get from eating meat and organs and then
if you want fiber i'm gonna send you
some mangoes or papaya from costa rica
or i'm sure
or wherever you are you can find bananas
or other fruit there's plenty of fiber i
mean fiber is a whole separate
discussion which we don't have to get
into unless you really want to but
because i'm animal based now and i'm
eating fruit i think that
there's a lot of ways people can get
fiber from fruit
you don't necessarily need more fiber
from vegetables and
i mean i think both women and men will
appreciate this i think that
most people that i speak to when they
cut the vegetables out of their diet or
decrease them they they have less gas
they fart less they have less bloating
their gi systems get better which is
just easier to be a human when you can
be around people and not have to like
sneak over the corner to like you know
fart or something
i can't say that's a huge problem but i
mean i'm definitely interested in the
oxalate side of things and the part
where it makes the um nutrients less
bioavailable and or or is actually
counterproductive
um so okay does this apply basically to
all vegetables i mean i know you know
there's some obviously some doctors that
have made lectins pretty um
pretty a pretty big conversation piece
when it comes to health i think gundry's
kind of led the way on that
so i have done
after interviewing him i i definitely
steer clear of more of those but i do
get confused then when it comes to okay
what about broccoli what about
cauliflower what about zucc and while
the zucchini is a lectin
but you know some of those other ones is
it oxalates being the main
thing that is dangerous in some of those
other vegetables that make them either
make them you know counterproductive in
the body oxalates are just one of the
problems there's like
there's many
issues we can talk about
the brassica family which is kale
cauliflower broccoli
brussels sprouts
um too yeah they're all in this this
brassica family so we can talk about
that that's a really interesting
conversation yeah so let's just define
vegetables people understand vegetable
versus fruit so vegetable is and this is
actually you can put on your like
delorean 75 000 years ago hat a
vegetable is any part of a plant that's
not a fruit so if you think like a plant
and you know and you're rooted in the
ground as a plant you have roots and you
have a stem and sometimes the stem is
woody and you have leaves and then you
make seeds and the seeds are like your
babies you're going to encase your dna
and the seed all the information to make
a new plant somewhere else it's either
going to get dispersed by wind or it's
going to be in a sweet fruit which is
going to drop to the ground and get
eaten and hopefully the seed gets pooped
out somewhere else or you know the birds
come and they disperse your seeds
because they want to eat the fruit so
anything that's not a fruit is a
vegetable
technically so you're thinking about
vegetables are things like seeds so
grains nuts seeds and beans are all
vegetables
leaves are vegetables so spinach kale
chard
stems are vegetables things like celery
or what are some other stems sometimes
like asparagus is kind of like a stem
and then roots are also vegetables
this is just the differentiation and if
you think like a plant does a plant want
any part of its body
other than a fruit to be eaten
the answer is pretty clearly no like if
animals go around eating plant leaves
and bark and stems and roots they're
killing the plants which makes it less
likely for the plant to reproduce so
like the reason you don't see animals or
insects
just running around eating all of the
plants in front of you whether it's in
central park or wherever you are is
because those plants put defense
chemicals in their leaves in their bark
in their roots and in their seeds
especially that's part of the discussion
around lectins is these carbohydrate
binding proteins that are mostly present
in seeds
things like you know
beans our seeds right those are a big
source of lectins a lot of nuts are
problematic lectin containing foods for
humans so
there are lots of defense chemicals in
seeds that go even beyond the lectins
there's oxalates there's phytic acid
that we talked about but there are other
defense chemicals in leaves so in the
case of kale cauliflowers
chard
all of these brassica vegetables you
have a whole family of compounds with
this complex name
isothiocyanates and yes in the name it
sort of has like a cyanide type of thing
and they are related in some ways to
that compound they don't work exactly
the same but there's pretty good
evidence
that certain that amounts of brussels
sprouts and certain types of kale that
people eat contain enough of these
isothiocyanates like one specifically is
called goitrin to inhibit iodine
absorption at the level of the thyroid
and create potential for hypothyroidism
which is also called goiter so maybe
you've seen pictures of people
in africa or central america with a
really big thick necks have you seen
that like the real that's a goiter
that's a goiter and it's from
hypothyroidism
because these people are eating
so many of the foods that have these
goitrogenic compounds
things like cassava you know is a common
root eaten in central america and
they're not eating enough foods with
iodine things like fish or meat and
organs of animals so if you're not
eating enough animal foods and you're
eating a lot of plant foods with these
defense chemicals that attack your
thyroid and prevent iodine absorption
you become iodine deficient and you get
this pathological goiter this huge thick
neck wow and these people are forced to
do this because of poverty and they
can't hunt and their hunting grounds
have been destroyed because they're no
longer living as hunter-gatherers so
this is the concern and again this is
what my work is about is asking
questions getting people to really think
like
is my thyroid healthy like
do i check my thyroid do i check more
than just a tsh like am i having
autoimmune thyroid issues but i'm still
eating broccoli um is it possible i'm
eating too many oxalates
[Music]